[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dragon spacex com track ground stitches
we got to see iss out the window which
was pretty neat
[Music]
the largest window ever flown in spain
we have liftoff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
gwen welcome to stanford thank you very
much i'm really excited to be here
actually i love this school
um
i've been looking forward to this
interview for a very long time as i know
have many of my classmates
a bit of a space nerd i as a kid would
read all the space books over the 60s
apollo 14 was my favorite movie i think
still is my favorite movie clean crayons
the mythical flight director was a
childhood hero
so it's really great to have you
to me space has always been about the
next frontier and testing the limits of
what is possible
and today nobody embodies that better
than spacex and your story
so with that let's get started one of
the defining characteristics of spacex
uh is is risk-taking but the same can be
said about you joining the company 20
years ago
this year after stable career in
aerospace what led you to join spacex
and take that risk at that time
well first of all i want to start out by
saying thank goodness i took that risk
because i almost didn't in fact and when
elon asked me to be president in 2008 i
almost didn't say yes
what a mistake that would have been
um
yeah so i was in the aerospace industry
i started i started my engineering
career
when was it in 86 went to chrysler
motors went back to school because i was
unsatisfied with the level of technology
that i was working on there um went back
to university thought i'd get my phd
wacky so that i can't be in school again
i'm gonna go back to work and so i went
to aerospace and i think i started in
88.
interestingly i started on halloween in
1988 at the aerospace corporation
and my boss um
wasn't there when i started but came
back a week later he was on vacation and
he said something about flying in on my
broom
in 1988 which you can't say now
but he could say it then so the world is
changing even if we feel like it's too
slow
um
yeah so okay so started my career in 88
um in the aerospace industry and thought
had been there for roughly 15 years
roughly
and i thought look it's it wasn't a an
industry that was vibrant it wasn't
innovative we weren't moving quickly we
hadn't gotten back to the moon
and i thought you know this is my last
job in the aerospace industry working
for elon if we can't do it at spacex
then i'd rather
sell real estate or be a barista or
you know something else i did i wouldn't
i didn't want to work in the industry
and so um i knew this would be my last
job in the aerospace industry and it
will turn out to be the case so that's
super cool all right about risk yeah you
guys are about risk and i'm blabbing
around sorry okay um so it seemed risky
actually i had a very stable job i owned
three percent share of the company that
i was working for which is large for um
for for for a for an employee
and uh
it was a pretty safe job so this was not
a safe job and i didn't know elon well
at all in fact at that time
um
but i i really kind of jumped off the
cliff
i was dithering around he said he wanted
me to join the company and i said oh you
know i'm fine i don't need a job and
kind of dithered for about a month and
finally like i'm such an idiot i was
driving on the freeway in l.a like what
an idiot say yes so i called him on the
phone and i said
bleep an idiot and he laughed and he
said welcome to the team
so you got sold on the idea right yeah
had a lot of confidence if you thought
it was going to be your last job um last
job on the industry
fair enough
um but your first job was vice president
of business development so now you had
to sell that idea to customers yes and
spacex was little more than a pipe dream
at the time right you were many years
away from launch what was that selling
process like
you know it's interesting when you when
you don't have a product we had an ideal
to sell and it came at probably the best
possible time
um
you know we had the events of 911 and
rapid launch low cost access to space be
it was obvious that it was going to be
very critical
and so it was
great engineers i am not going to take
away in fact spacex is the great company
and does the great things that we do
because of our extraordinary staff it's
not because me it's not because of elon
and
and so i was selling the team
i was selling the ideal i was selling
the promise and the hope of reason
reasonably priced launch i i still don't
think launch is reasonably priced but if
you go by comparison it's much less than
it was before
we're getting there yeah so let's talk
about launch and about the first rocket
right um the first rocket was called the
falcon one uh you had three unsuccessful
launches
it was 2008 the company
was running out of money it was the
financial crisis you were promoted to
present ceo because of promises you had
made customers at this point so you'd
already been promoted
and the company bet the entire company
in this one launch on the fourth launch
of the falcon one so let's watch that
launch
five
four
three
two
one zero print stage one liftoff
indication
one launch vehicle falcon has cleared
the tower
plus 12.
curious thank goodness
right so uh it's a life or death moment
for the company right um
is a little more dramatic about that
launch than i am actually i figured we
could pull a fifth launch off but that
was it
right yeah i thought we could get to
five he thought four was it
i'm glad we didn't have to test who was
right on that one but
uh yeah it was quite a relief and what
were the moms leading up to it like what
was the
well this is a really this is i think
it's a hilarious story i was in
scotland glasgow the iac
was having a show in glasgow so i was in
scotland
to
apologize discuss explain to the
customers that were on the third falcon
one launch that we failed
kind of basically do a paper about that
launch and it was the night before my
talk
i was
in the hotel room with my husband and
this is not gonna get inappropriate um
my husband was sleeping i'm in the
bathroom with the shower on typing up a
proposal for the 1.6 billion dollar con
nasa resupply to the international space
station we're literally writing the
proposal i'm on the phone with my team
back in the us because we had to update
our pricing and so i had the shower
running so that my you know poor husband
could sleep
i'm like punching away talking
and then it's like oh shoot we're we're
about ready to launch right and so i
turned away from my proposal on my
laptop to
to the launch and uh was watching it
as we lift it off i ran out to the hotel
room and i didn't care if i woke him up
at this point at this stage we lifted
off and we were climbing in altitude and
um and we watched us get to orbit and
then in my
like yoga pants and jammy top
ran down the hall that's probably the
most inappropriate thing i'm going to
say here today but ran down the hall
knocked on all the doors from my team
that was there and we
hugged and kissed and cried and then
kind of broke into the bar in the hotel
because it was like two in the morning
and they
they they let us have the champagne but
it was warm but it was it was
extraordinary it was extraordinary i've
always loved how emotional a business
this is right yeah these are just
incredible emotional moments right in
fact by the way to future entrepreneurs
i think it's really important to have
these big moments figure out what the
big moments where you can bring your
teams together it cures a lot of ills
it really helps with morale and it's
incredible for team building so
launches are easy it's an easy spectacle
to do that with but i think it's really
important to find those kinds of moments
in the development for your future
businesses
so let's actually move forward a few
years your first big kind of commercial
product was the falcon 9. it was
designed in part of nasa's needs in mind
to replace the internet the space
shuttle to go to the national space
station you had done a number of
launches already including seven
resupply missions to the international
space station with nasa right and the
eighth one was also supposed to take
critical food supplies medical equipment
international space station but that one
didn't go as well let's watch that video
that's this is two minutes into flight
daddy coming back show us vehicle on
course on track
poof yeah
you had made it seem routine almost at
this point right um
and then this happens
you're in crisis management mode what's
the first thing you do
yeah so i was actually at my ranch in
texas on this launch it was the first
launch that uh i was
not um
that therefore yeah um by the way it was
also the first and only launch that i
didn't do my pre-launch
um
little routine
which we could chat about later but
because i was in my slippers and uh
so um
i think the most important thing when
you suffer something like that is you
focus everybody on the job the task at
hand right we had failure in front of us
on elon's birthday by the way that was
his birthday um which is why we don't
like to launch on his birthday it just
feels like bad karma actually
um
so uh you get to work i had to do a
press conference doing it remotely of
course
um
and we started digging through data of
course we obviously i've i flew back to
hawthorne and
pulled teams together and we figured it
out was it was a weird one
that one and then
so this was in on june 28 2015
and then we suffered another failure was
not a launch failure on september 1st
2016
not
a little over a year later right
um
and
we basically blew up a satellite that
was sitting on the pad as we were going
through a pre-launch test
so two failures not back to back we had
had an extraordinary success in december
of 2015 and we can come back to that as
well but this is a this is a point that
i try to make with students for sure so
i think after the crs-7 that first
failure that failure that you saw there
i i felt very comfortable leading the
team through the investigation leading
the team through the physics and getting
to the answer
the business wasn't really at risk
i mean failures are incredibly impactful
i think every failure we've had has
either cost us or delayed us about half
a billion dollars
but i felt like i did a pretty good job
in that time frame i did not do a good
job after the failure uh when we blew up
on the pet
i was much more worried about the
business
this particular event um was much harder
to figure out what it was
and i i definitely showed my
not despair that's probably too much but
my concern i definitely
wore it on my sleeve or as my husband
says i have a billboard on my
forehead and i i wore that
badly in fact so my lesson there is you
know you certainly don't want to be
disingenuous with your team and with
your customers
but it's not really helpful to
show your anxiety when you know when
you're suffering because your employees
are suffering worse than you are so it's
really better to
keep people focused on the business keep
focused on doing great things and they
had demonstrated that they could do
great work until then too so
um yeah so that's a nice little nugget
yeah thanks for sharing that
so one of the things in particular for
this first failure that i find
incredible is
you had six months without launches
which i'm sure you had a bunch scheduled
that were delayed right but six months
later you're launching a rocket again uh
but instead of simply focusing on
getting that rocket and the customer's
payload up into space successfully you
take a huge risk as well and try to land
the booster right do you have that video
and i have that video
and i know it's your favorite yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the crown goes wild
it was a mosh pit out there was so fun
why was this so exciting okay so
what's key about that is the last launch
or the launch just prior to that one we
failed you know and it's disappointing
for the employees it's disappointing for
the company but we failed our customer
this launch so we stood down we
discovered what the problem was
we redesigned the rocket to be able to
land because the previous rockets really
couldn't land in that way so we complete
we did a complete upgrade on the system
while figuring out what we did to fail
and then like in complete view of the
public
you go out there and you show are you
are you meant for greatness or you need
to go back to the drawing board a little
bit so
that was a great
a great day
it was a great night we had a lot of
champagne at my house
that night probably more than i've ever
drank ever
i did not feel great the next day but i
did go to work i went to work
um
yeah so that was an extraordinary moment
for the company just
share with us a little bit why it's so
important to the whole business model
yeah sorry um
well first of all no one had ever landed
a rocket before right that was the start
and the key piece of the technology
necessary to reuse rockets
so some i know there are some space
nerds out there but there are many of
you that are not by the way if you are a
space nerd you should wear that proudly
i certainly do
um but rockets before spacex and to some
extent the shuttle did it but
but
there was there's no fully reusable
launch system rockets launch
and then they either disintegrate in the
atmosphere the second stage does or they
just get dumped into the ocean right now
and so
imagine what
air travel would be like if you took an
airplane from
san francisco
to new york and you had to toss the
aircraft after that flight
like life and society in the world would
be so different
if you couldn't reuse your aircraft and
so we take that same approach
with space travel
that you have to be able to reuse your
rockets in order to facilitate human
access to space which i think is
incredibly important so that was the
start and we had tried many times before
um
we tried parachutes but they rip off in
this as speeding through the atmosphere
so that was just an extraordinary piece
of technology guidance navigation and
control
you know hyper retroactive propulsion
crazy hypersonic retroactive propulsion
was just amazing so that
was great and it started our ability to
refly rockets we didn't refly that one
that one is sitting outside the front of
our building in hawthorne california you
can drive by it and see it in fact it's
kind of a neat monument
but we have i don't want to say
perfected because we have not perfected
but we have operationalized the ability
to land rockets refurbish them and
re-fly them our goal is to be able to do
that like an airplane like i was saying
in the back room
you know they said something someone
asked something about you know
rocket efficiency and we're not very
efficient we we actually aspire to be as
efficient as the airline industry and
that's probably horrifying to many of
you in the audience because you probably
don't think the airline industry is
particularly efficient but it's way
better than we are um so it's still a
nice model to use right yeah so after
this in 2015 this really became routine
spacex was launching dozens and dozens
of trips up into space
every year um in may 2020 the beginning
of the pandemic you took another huge
leap and it involved humans right you
launched two astronauts to the national
space station the first astronauts to
launch on a private vehicle and the
first to do so from american soil on any
vehicle in nine years right we were
doing it with the russians
um how did you carry that responsibility
and how do you prepare the team for it
so
first of all keep your head high don't
show your anxiety but i honestly hate
crew launch days i just don't like them
uh it's nerve-racking it's one thing to
you know to have a have a failure when
you've got a satellite even a billion
dollar three billion dollar satellite on
top
you can't put a price tag on the two to
four people that are sitting on top of
that rocket and it's hurtling
through the atmosphere so it's quite
anxiety
producing
um it's always a huge relief to
get get dragged into orbit get dragged
into the international space station and
then say okay nasa they're yours now
until we have to bring them back
downhill
six months later um
so keep people focused on the work for
sure don't let them show your ex you
know don't let them see my anxiety even
though i've talked about this enough
they all know i'm like scared to death
during launch days on this follow your
routine be keenly aware
make sure you've got employees that feel
very comfortable talking about hey
i might have screwed this up can we go
back and look at the data and make sure
that i didn't screw this up on the
rocket or the spaceship so
um
yeah
keep them focused on the business
don't show how nervous you are
and
pray
so even this has become routine now i
think you've launched four trips to the
national space station something like
that so we did
bob and doug and then we just flew crs4
and then we also flew axiom yeah and
then we did jared and his team that's
true okay so so seven so let's talk
about the future then because you know
um
and let's talk about starship which is
the big bet you have as a future or this
rocket was previously called the big
falcon rocket bfr bfr um
who who chose to rename it
well elon named it the first time
and elon named it the second time got it
um there was one in between two its
i think interstellar or something yeah
yeah exactly yeah um starship is better
what's so different about this bet and
what does it mean for humanity so the
difference here for those of you that
are not space geeks this first stage
goes up delivers the second stage to
carry on its way to orbit comes back so
we reuse the first stage but the second
stage is now reusable it goes to orbit
it drops off the payload takes people
around the moon takes people to mars
whatever it is and then it comes back
and lands our second stage right now is
not reusable on the falcon program our
third stage if you look at a dragon is
reusable not very operationally right it
lands in the ocean
get helicopters and ships to go get it
out of the water take it back clean off
the salt water refurbish it and refly it
but a dragon takes currently like 90
days we're trying to get it down to
45 and then even faster but that's not
very operationally efficient starship is
meant to launch
land on the pad
on the pad
the arms come and pick up another
another starship pick it up put it back
on the pad and launch within an hour so
like an airplane
that's the plan
and it's supposed to take us either to
shanghai or to mars right
yeah right hopefully some version of
this would take us to another star
system
right which would be so great
um so i want to talk about the
development of this because there's
something remarkable about that
as you mentioned it's supposed to be
fully reusable
i saw many estimates online but each one
of these costs somewhere around 200
million to build that might be a wild
guess
um
but your product development strategy
seems to be to blow one of these up
every few months right so let's take a
look at starship number nine
we're prepared by preparing to restart
two engines flip the vehicle vertical
then transition to one engine for the
landing burn
so
that seems expensive
and completely different to how
traditional rocket technology where it's
like they make the whole rocket as
perfectly as possible they wind test it
and they say once it's perfect we try to
you know flight test it these are
prototypes that you just keep going
um
what's behind that way of thinking about
rocket technology so
and this isn't very well understood
publicly i'm a little surprised we don't
talk more about it we are much more
focused for the starship program on
production building the system that will
build the system than we are on the
rocket technology itself i didn't touch
anything no you did
all right
i break hardware by walking by so this
makes me nervous um
so we know how to get rockets to orbit
we know how to do that
this is a completely different one but
we we're very confident in our ability
to figure out how to do that we were
much more focused on can we produce a
rocket
that can get to orb like really produce
falcon we produce you know between seven
and eleven falcon first stages per year
we're producing a second stage every
week right now
but what we want to be able to do is
produce a rocket a day or come much
closer to automotive
because if you are going to take people
to mars you're going to go in a flotilla
or a swarm i don't even know yet right
what the right term is yet for a group
of starships to head to mars
you're going to need a bunch of them
and
producing five a year isn't going to get
you there you really want to launch
hundreds
on that cyanotic period with mars when
you're taking people there
um
so we need to have a production system
build rockets much like a production
system to build cars maybe not quite so
many i don't think we need a million a
year
but uh we need more than
a couple hundred
so it's all about the production system
so we will get this to orbit i'm not
saying that it's easy because it's very
different you'll see the way well not
the orbital part but the the landing
part is very different you know we belly
flop to dissipate the heat
and then come vertical right at the last
second
it's different from the way we're doing
it on falcon but we i mean we and we did
it we stuck a landing
bringing
it back no it wasn't from orbit it was
just from altitude it was not from orbit
so
you're trying to do really hard things
and i want to talk about what that a
little bit right spacex has the most
ambitious goals on the tightest of
timelines and actually quick question
what's our latest timeline on getting to
mars
getting to mars oh i think we'll put
people down within a decade right
so
you're in charge of i know i'm crazy
you're in charge of executing on that
goal to get human beings to mars within
a decade right that's more elon than me
but i'm here to help right
but how do you balance those ambitious
goals right which like maybe elon comes
out and says
and
getting the team comfortable that is
possible
so there's a couple of strategies to do
that first of all you always aim high we
have achieved everything we have wanted
to never in the timeline we fail on
timeline but that feels like the right
fail to make as opposed to not achieving
what you're trying to achieve
technically um
so
you demonstrate that you've been able to
do these crazy insane absurdly ambitious
things in the past
you can continue you know pump people up
to do it again and you try to pull apart
these the seemingly impossible situation
and how are we going to design and
develop this and you pull it into
smaller pieces you build a prototype you
test it you put prototypes you know
subsystems together and you test that
and you kind of use a building block
approach to reach your goals
and the team
they're very enthusiastic about it like
it's the biggest of goals
rockets are super cool yeah
so you've been at spacex for
over 20 years now this year yeah and now
you lead a team basically 12 000 people
um what have you learned about your
leadership style
over the years what do you wish you knew
now that and you knew then that you know
now
oh
let me answer the other stuff first um
i'm not a regretter so it's really hard
for me to kind of go back and say oh i
wish i did this thing um
i'm a very collaborative leader actually
i've got some employees here you can
tell me if i'm a bs artist here or not
i like to get to solicit people's
opinions but i'm not afraid to make a
decision
i need more data than elon does to make
a decision in fact
and i don't know whether that's
experience or
or risk taking i don't know what it is
but i like a little bit more data but i
definitely
like making decisions i like to hear the
conversation until you're done and you
have to make a decision and it's rare
that you get people to agree on any
topic right so you collect the best data
that you can you listen as hard as you
can you ask questions you bring more
data back and then you gotta go
yeah
um
so
a slightly different question
your job is to run the business right
sometimes things come up in the
organization
that are core to the culture uh that are
according to who you are as an
organization um the sexual misconduct
allegations against elon last week are
just maybe one example of that i'm
wondering how you think about those
moments those moments of truth and how
you think about responding to different
stakeholders
so i think leaders in any business
face adversity and really hard
challenges and i what's most important
is that you first of all you think hard
about what happened what the response is
going to be and i think you just have to
be really honest with yourself about
what the right approach is
i did send a letter i came out last
night very exciting for this particular
discussion here i did send a letter to
employees they were screaming to hear
from me
and i was advised to not send that
letter
not by legal but by my press team and i
said you know what i
first i have to speak to the people i
have to speak to my employees they're
you know the reason why spacex is what
it is and i care deeply about them but i
knew i would
no matter which way i played that
someone was going to be unhappy with me
but i i had to say it i have worked for
elon for 20 years i don't believe he
could have done what was
what he was accused of but he is
imperfect right he's imperfect i'm
imperfect and i thought being honest
about that was the right approach
regardless of what my team told me to
write or not what was left out of that
letter by the way is the end where i
basically say we are
spacex is who we are because of you
and if you ever feel uncomfortable at
work please call me
right so that part's always left off
right um
at any rate so you face adversity and i
think the only way to get through it is
to
make sure you understand the situation
to the greatest extent you can and then
be honest with yourself and
pick a path and and do it and don't be
afraid to say you made a mistake if you
make a mistake right yeah
i'm irish that's very irish by the way
to admit
you were
dummy
and i'm not admitting that in this case
by the way i'm just saying one should
be willing to do that speaking of
mistakes i've heard that spacex has a
culture of feedback that's something we
take very seriously here at the gsb as
well we have a whole class where we
learn how to give feedback
feedback is a gift as a continuous motto
of the school almost
i'm wondering how spacex operationalizes
that in the day-to-day
so
critically important feed 360 feedback
and immediate the sooner you get
feedback the better off you are that's a
golden nugget of data on how you are
impacting your co-workers your company
the
project so that feedback is so critical
so give feedback as quickly as you can
and we always
try to
tell people to do it our review system
we require that you get reviewed 360
feedback from at least three
you know sometimes in you know if you've
got employees that have you know that
are really great in some areas and
really not great in other areas you try
to solicit more feedback to figure out
what's going on in those areas and try
to work with them to figure out how you
can get people to this place where it's
all contribution all the time
so so it's in our review system
uh we talk about it at the first day of
work please you know give feedback um
but
engineers and well you know it's not
really human nature to be willing to
look someone in the eye and say
hey that was not helpful not super
helpful
could you do it this way you know be
objective
try to not personalize it in almost
every case and it feedback could be
technical it doesn't have to be like hey
you were a total jerk to me and i'm
really mad about it um
but in almost every case the person at
least in my experience
person is not malinten not intending to
do bad things they either made a mistake
they were unaware
um so i think approaching it as not part
taking it not personal but just talk
about how this situation impacted you or
how this person's work caused your work
to not be great you couldn't finish your
project or whatever it's just really
important
that's exactly what we we preached here
as well yep um
before we go to q a and i know that a
lot of great questions in the audience
two questions again about the future
first and you already made a reference
to this
what comes after mars
yeah so um we are not working on a ship
that yet has the propulsion technology
to take us to other star systems but i
certainly hope that mars is that example
that shows that humans can live beyond
planet earth
and that we will focus on propulsion
technologies or some way of getting to a
place that would otherwise take four
thousand or five thousand years
so i'm very excited about that it will
not happen in my lifetime but i hope
that some of the work that we're doing
will kick off
the
aspiration to go do that like the shows
that you watch you know we we can't
and they're always about war by the way
star wars like what is that i don't
star trek is not necessarily about war
but it's still military i don't know why
it is that way but um hopefully we can
go there in a civilian way and
meet other
sentient beings
and that would be great
yeah that would be quite something so
for
uh
for this for the second question i
actually want to bring us back to earth
to this auditorium because many of us
are thinking about our very immediate
futures i checked this morning i
graduate in two and a half
weeks as do many of my classmates here
you're our last view from the top
speaker of the year you have the stage
what advice would you have for us as we
embark on the next chapter of our lives
so it's a very simple statement and i'll
follow it up with a couple of examples
you want to take risks in your career
you absolutely want to take risks yeah
maybe in your life too although you have
to balance right you got to balance it
um i almost said no to elon when he
asked me to join spacex
would have been so
i would look back i'm not a regretter
that is the one thing that i would go
back and regret
i almost said no when elon asked
me to be president because i really
loved my job my
colleagues my
brother and sister vps were great
compatriots and i thought it might be
weird to be the boss
so i almost said no
um
and i'm so glad that i didn't but it
felt like a risk to to
to say yes there
and then this is a more personal risk
um
so when i first met my current husband
husband number two sorry
um
we had our first date and
i thought he was roughly my age roughly
my age and then he said something about
the gulf war and you know wanting to
have been a pilot i was like
go form like help and i were in the car
and i looked over i'm like how old are
you
and he he was about eight years younger
than me and i was like
not interested
why would i go out with this infant no
way
and and luckily
luckily i i
didn't take that little voice in my head
and i took the risk and dated a much
younger man and
happily married so it's
not really silly but a little personal
but i almost said i am not going to date
someone that's 8 years younger than me
that is weird
anyhow took the risk paid off
what uh what a great note to end on so
with that um
yeah
before we close and we are almost out of
time i want to do a traditional view
from the top lightning round oh okay
ready i'm very terrible at these okay
would you rather live in the univer
universe or the metaverse
i'm not sure what the metaverse is by
the way but i think i'm all universe all
the time there's a lot of students here
who know what the better verse i don't
yeah um
what are your favorite pre-launch
rituals which you mentioned before oh i
put uh the inside of my shoes with
sticky notes that say scotland
on them so i am in scotland for every
launch because we got to orbit for the
first time when i was in scotland
yep and the only gross thing about that
is there if i don't take them out right
away you like stepping on paper and it
kind of disintegrates and then you get
like feet paper
all over the place and you really have
to vacuum it up it's pretty gross
toast lunch rituals
i don't have a post launch ritual
actually favorite celebration champagne
every time no every launch well
we're launching a lot
maybe not every time maybe not every
time
certainly not during the day at work
that's an at-home thing favorite space
movie
firefly and that's the show but there
also was a movie firefly
hands down
and you have a starship at your disposal
it's yours you can go anywhere
on earth or into space where would you
take it i go to the moon
orbit or land i would like to land
successfully
yeah i love the moon and why the moon
and not mars
mars is six months
um it's further
uh i don't like to camp
so
you're you're you're traveling for six
months
to really camp in the most extreme way
humans have ever camped
whereas camping on the moon it feels
like ah if you hate it you just
just come home
or you can you can put up with it for a
couple of days and then you just get
home mars you're kind of stuck for two
years
please welcome me in thanking
grandchildren
[Applause]
[Music]
you